-What's up, Jimmy?
-Welcome back to the show.
I have a lot things
to discuss with you.
-Sure.
First is you were
fantastic on the Grammy's, the
50th, the tribute to hip-hop.
50 years -- 50 years of hip-hop.
-Yes, sir.
-And you crushed it,
everyone did.
What was it like?
What'd it feel like?
-It was good, I mean,
based off the fact that,
you know, the rap category
wasn't televised
on the Grammys
for so many years.
It was -- it was cool.
You know, it's kind of like
full circle for me
'cause I had actually
won a Grammy
in pre-telecast so I wasn't
able to make
the big speech in front of the
crowd and stuff like that.
-They never aired it?
-Never did.
So, to be on that stage
performing,
oh, man, that was best.
-Yeah.
And what was backstage like?
-Backstage was crazy because,
you know, that green room,
off the chain.
-Right?
-Yeah.
-I mean Ice-T was in there,
and Ice-T tells
all the best stories.
-Dude, Ice-T is the best.
-He got all the best stories.
-He comes on, I go,
"Just tell me something."
-Facts. I love that dude.
-Wait, he just said
something about you.
-He said that this is his first
time meeting Wu-Tang Clan.
I doubt if I was there because I
don't remember it,
but he said first time he met us
we were gonna kick his ass.
Or he thought -- he thought we
were gonna kick is ass.
But it turns he that, you know,
we were fans, he was a fan,
and it was all love from there.
-But -- but why would you ever
fight Ice-T?
-We wouldn't, but you know,
back then,
those where our grimey years.
Everything we did looked
intimidating.
You know what I'm saying?
-Yeah, I know
what you're saying.
-Yeah.
-I know, obviously,
you're in Wu-Tang,
but I heard that your kids first
words were Wu-Tang.
-Yup, my first son.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, y'all laughing.
I mean...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Honestly.
-Isn't that rad?
-I mean, I'm glad
they found it funny
'cause I'm just glad it
wasn't a curse word.
[ Laughter ]
-That's actually good, yeah.
-Yeah, 'cause kids
pick up on things really quick.
-But his first...?
-Wu-Tang, mm-hmm.
-Really?
-Wu-Tang, Wu-Tang, yes, sir.
-We actually found audio
of this.
-This is Method Man's...
-That's dope.
...son saying his first words,
Wu-Tang.
Listen.
-What's that, Shaquan?
-Wu-Tang.
-What's that?
[ Laughter ]
-Wu-Tang.
-He's gonna love that.
-Yeah, he's gonna love that.
-Did you -- did you just always
have tapes around
or bring him to the studio?
-Actually, what I did in that
whole process,
because he was already
saying it.
What I did was I had this tattoo
of Wu-Tang on my hand
right here, so I would point
to it.
I was like, "What's that
Shaquan? Wu-Tang.
Who's your favorite group,
Shaquan? Wu-Tang."
-So, whatever you do,
he just say that.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You've been getting
more into acting now recently.
Congratulations on that.
-Thank you.
-You're crushing it, by the way.
You're really --
I want to get into this.
Now that the show is going well,
this is Season 3,
it's getting picked up again,
I want to talk about auditions.
And do you every remember
any auditions
that didn't go so well?
-Yeah, I'm glad you
brought that up.
-Yeah, no problem. That's why --
that's why I'm here, bud.
-Alright, so I had to audition
for a movie
called "Money Monster."
-Okay.
-Jodie Foster directed it,
George Clooney, I believe,
was staring in it.
And yeah, I had to read.
So I'm super prepared, right?
I'm sitting in the waiting room
for, you know, for the read.
Couple of producers show up,
then one more producer shows
and he's like, "Meth,
you're my guy.
I can't wait till you
go up in there.
Kill it, Meth.
No, no worries.
No, no worries whatsoever.
Just kill it."
I'm like this is my guy here.
I'm gonna kill it for this guy.
-Yes.
-But what I didn't know was
there were waiting
for one more person.
-Okay.
-And that last person showed
up about two minutes later
and it was Jodie Foster.
Now, for me -- yeah, ooh.
For me, it was like the same
reaction, oh, man,
now it's Jodie Foster
in the room
and I'm a big fan.
Her work speaks for itself.
-She's the best.
-I get up in this room, Jimmy,
oh, my God.
Um, alright.
It started off good, 'cause,
you know,
then I caught a brain fart.
From there,
I couldn't remember a thing.
So, it gets worse though.
I start sweating. I have a
little mini anxiety attack.
Start sweating crazy,
so now I'm looking for anything
in the room to dry myself
off with.
The guy has a box of Kleenex.
-Yeah.
-If you know anything
about Kleenex,
when they get wet, what happens?
So I'm trying to dry myself off
with the Kleenex.
I got paper stuck to my face.
[ Laughter ]
All I can think
is Jodie Foster thinks
I'm, like, this idiot right now.
-[ Laughs ] Exactly.
-And I kindly excused myself and
walked out, that was it.
-Did you ever see any
of them ever again?
-I haven't seen anybody that was
in that room ever again,
but if I ever run it -- if I
ever run into Jodie,
hopefully she doesn't remember
and I would love
to work with her.
-Yeah, exactly.
-There you go.
-Well, I love you take that
and you get back up.
-Yes, sir.
-And you're crushing it on
"Power Book II."
-Yeah.
-I want to say congratulations.
You won two?
-Three.
-Three Image awards?
-Yeah.
-Come on, bud.
-And, yeah, the thing about
that, the most important part
about that is I think
the word Image.
-Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
-Exactly.
-Especially from the background
that I come from,
that lets people know
that you can't count the down
and out out for too long
'cause some day they're
gonna have their day.
And boy, when it comes, whoo,
it's a beautiful thing.
-It's a beautiful thing.
-I hope -- I hope you're
enjoying it.
-Yes, I am.
-You're crushing it.
-Now, on Season Three,
does it get a bit easier
now that it's kind
of home to you?
You're the people that people
get nervous around you.
-Yeah.
-People get tissues, tissues
stuck their head
auditioning for you, bud.
You're the new Jodie Foster,
bud.
-I would love -- you know what?
I would love
to be a fly on the wall in some
of these auditions,
especially for people that's
coming onto this show
because it's such a big hit now.
We had great numbers.
-I just saw that.
Yeah, our premiere episode had
great numbers.
-It already got --
-Thanks to the viewers.
-It already got picked up
for another season.
-Yeah, for another season.
We're actually filming
Season four now,
and I'm way over my quota
in nude scenes
so you might want
to check it out.
-[ Laughs ] My God.
-For real.
-How do we explain
"Power Book II: Ghost"
and who you play?
-I play a lawyer named
Davis Maclean.
"Power" is a spin-off of the
original "Power" series
which was done brilliantly
by Omari Hardwick,
Courtney Kemp
and 50 Cents project.
So this is the spin-off,
and it's based of off
the original character's son,
played by Michael Rainey.
Basically, him trying to
navigate through life
being a drug dealer,
as well as a college student.
And I'm the lawyer that pretty
much keeps him out of trouble.
-Yeah, yeah,
and you do a great job.
I want to show everybody a clip.
Here's in Method Man in
"Power Book II: Ghost."
Take a look.
-Since Zeke was killed the same
night as his father
in Spear's hanger,
they're looking into
the possibility
they were targeted
by the same doer.
-Who do they think that was?
-Ah, I say your guess is as good
as theres.
They logged .45 caliber
shell casings,
but that's a long shot a best.
Partial prints lead nowhere,
any potential witness
scattered like rats
and that's all she wrote.
-[ Bleep ]
I need more.
-Mrs. Tejada, Monet.
Mrs. Tejada works.
-Okay, Mrs. Tejada.
[ Clears throat ]
That's the NYPD's entire
file on the case.
There's nothing more to get.
Whoever did this either
meticulous or chaotic
enough to have New York's finest
scratching their head.
-Yeah, come on, now.
-Whoo! Whoo!
-Method Man,
"Power Book II: Ghost"
airs Fridays at 8:00 P.M.
on Starz
and it's streaming
on the Starz app.